under here what the gameplay needs to do
is immerse you in the world give you as
many interesting actions to survive in
this world and overcome obstacles and
obstacles could be infected it could be
other people it could just be the
environment it could be rushing water
anything it could happen in this
post-apocalyptic world yeah but more
than anything it needs to put you in
Elly's shoes that you're experiencing
what I was experiencing and it can you
feel what she feels because the more we
do that the more the emotional beats of
the story work for us and the more they
work for us in this very unique way that
only works in videogames
the gameplay philosophy of the last was
part two is putting you in the shoes of
Ellie and everything that that means it
means giving you a threat constantly as
this world has it means giving you the
hard choices because this game takes
place in such a hostile universe and our
characters are pushed to do really
difficult things we want to put you in
alignment with those choices we want you
to understand how hard certain decisions
were for these characters because
they're hard for you
I would say the overarching philosophy
of how we approached designing the game
mechanically is how can we take things
to the next next level everything kind
of comes out of this story and how do we
do it through systems so one is you have
to feel the pressure of survival survive
by the skin of my teeth how do I use all
these all the scrap around me any kind
of bullet any kind of rag and you kind
of bottle of alcohol how do we give you
that sense of being a survivor in this
world
[Applause]
[Music]
Elly is very small compared to Joel and
more nimble how do we make you feel like
you're not the strongest person in the
room but you still should be able to
rise to the challenge and survive you
know a fight with a bunch of people that
are all bigger than you do so therefore
it meant creating a character and
systems and mechanics that allow you to
be much more nimble and that's where we
added a jump button and the first thing
we had a climber button I'm not really
jumping and here Ellie can jump the
combat sonars are much more vertical
well he can use elevation to her
advantage
prone is a huge huge one prone obviously
it means to lay flat on the ground
something so simple again something that
in real life you'd be able to do letting
the player have access to all their
weapons all the items crafting
everything while in that position and it
just creates so many more emergent
things in gameplay now that we have this
other state that the player can be in
which they're very low to the ground how
else can we use this other than just
hiding and vegetation or like well
there's a lot of manmade things or
different structures that have collapsed
that allow just enough space for you to
crawl under and which means that now as
enemies are looking for you can crawl
under things and hide and it's just one
more way to assess your environment and
use it to Ellie's advantage now because
you can hide under the things we gave
the enemies we made them smarter and
gave them ability to look under things
so while you might hide somewhere and be
safe for a while eventually they're
gonna start looking under stuff and if
you're hiding in their truck and they
spot you they're gonna yank you out and
then try to kill you
[Music]
dodging is a big one because now with
dodge anytime you're in a you're in a
scuffle you have a chance to get away
you have a chance to counter-attack it
let's escape be an option as well
sometimes you just got to run and that
is another part of this world which is
sometimes the threat is so overpowering
that you just have to get away when you
are partially hidden or you'd like your
ingress that means people from afar can
see but people from closer can kind of
see you they will eventually acquire
you're not completely hidden when you're
in grass and it makes you as a player
become much more aware of your
surroundings
jump prone dodge you know all these
things feed into both exploration and
combat because it lets us expand the
space that the size of spaces can be
bigger the intricacy of spaces can be
more complex and it still works exactly
as you would expect so when it came to
our level design we really wanted to
challenge ourselves to make a world that
really felt like a real space as much as
we possibly could and didn't feel like a
series of combat encounters and
exploration spaces and combat encounters
that felt like a Hall of Horrors or
something but something that really felt
like a space that you could explore that
seemed like a legitimate urban
environment and that pushed us to make
our level design even more open than it
was in the first game which for us at
the time was was pretty open in this
game we've gone so far in making the
level design open that there are
actually entire story moments entire
combat encounters like full scripted
sequences that you may completely miss
and there are things that we feel like
even though the portion of our player
base may never see these things the fact
that when you do encounter them you feel
like you discovered them it lends them
this charm and this magic that I think
is unique to games that you know this
has happened to me because of what I did
and what the place I explored to
the crafting is very much about a payoff
to exploration meaning that when you
enter new spaces you want to look around
for supplies you want to open drawers
and cabinets and look for different
things that will allow you to craft
either items that can help you heal
items that can help you attack multiple
enemies at once such as the Molotov or
the landmine that alykum craft items
that can help augment your weapons like
a silencer for her pistol or craft new
kinds of ammo it also gives us tons of
interesting gameplay choices and
overlaps that you can do at any moment
and on the fly we try to be a game that
wants you to make a lot of different
decisions in combat as possible and the
way that we've expanded the recipe
roster and all of the recipes and how
they interact with each other is
carefully chosen for the different
ingredients and making sure that you
always have these interesting decisions
to make put a much stronger emphasis on
the importance of the choices you make
in the long term for your character
you'll be useful through the weapon
upgrade system to the player upgrade
system there aren't enough resources in
a single playthrough to fully upgrade
your character the choices that you make
you're gonna have to live with and we
wanted to make sure that all of the
choices that you made had a really
noticeable and tangible effect on the
way that you play you feel a greater
kinship with Ellie because you are
living with decisions that you've
already made like you you are continuing
this through line of her journey through
this world and the moment-to-moment
gameplay is influenced by that in a way
that we hadn't before the realization
that your choices have these long-term
consequences is very much like the
nature of the narrative of the game and
I'm happy that the mechanics are
supporting that
[Music]
PlayStation